a woman for so long revered
internationally as a voice of human
rights and democracy stayed silent as
she passed the press on her way into
court to the backdrop of protests
outside on San Souci traveled to the
Hague from Myanmar to defend an army
accused of genocide the very military
who kept her under house arrest for
years in court she showed no reaction as
lawyers detailed a catalogue of
atrocities from rape to murder committed
against the reinjure Muslim minority
sure that the Gambia asks is that you
tell me and man to stop these senseless
killings to stop these acts of babbity
and brutality that have shocked and
continue to shock our collective
conscience to stop this genocide of its
own people Sky News witnessed the mass
exodus of reinjure from Myanmar to
Bangladesh following a crackdown by the
military in 2017 and some who were
forced to flee made the journey to the
Hague to share their stories Yusuf Ali
showed us the wounds on his body he says
were inflicted by the Myanmar military
speaking to us through a translator my
think is he another ranger accused Aung
San su Chi who was awarded the Nobel
Peace Prize in 1991 a failing to stop
the attacks and killings and the UN's
highest court is being asked to order
special measures to protect the Muslim
minority the case has been brought by
Gambia
on behalf of dozens of Muslim nations
and she appears in court to lead
Myanmar's defense on sand suit
she is expected to repeat denials of
genocide and claim military operations
launched in 2017 were a legitimate
counterterrorism response to attacks on
security forces by rec injure militants
the hearing comes as the u.s.
blacklisted for Myanmar military leaders
for alleged human rights abuses but many
believe the country's de facto leaders
should be held complicit a woman so used
to global attention will be scrutinized
this week for all the wrong reasons
Michell turf at Sky News The Hague